c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la mobilisation pour
renforcer les rangs de l'armée en
République démocratique du Congo après
l'appel à la nation du président
s'engagent en masse dans les rangs de
l'armée pour lutter contre le M23 dans
l'est du pays reportage dans ce journal
la réouverture de la frontière entre le
Rwanda et le Burundi le réchauffement
entre les deux pays voisins intervient
après 7 ans de tension suite à une crise
électorale et une tentative de coup
d'État au Burundi reportage de notre
correspondant à suivre
et puis deux activistes Guinée en grève
de la fin il s'agit de deux leaders du
Front national pour la défense de la
Constitution ils avaient été arrêtés en
août dernier suite à des manifestations
il protester contre leur détention
qu'ils estiment illégales et sans
jugement nous serons à Conakry dans
cette édition
l'appel du président Tshisekedi semble
avoir été entendu selon l'armée
congolaise les jeunes veulent s'engager
en masse pour renforcer les rangs des
forces armées et lutter contre le M23
dans l'est du pays la milice rebelle a
pris le contrôle de plusieurs localités
dont bounagana ruchourou et kimanja je
vous propose de regarder ce reportage
signé Justin kabomba et Aurélie bazarra
kibangula dans les rues de Goma il
défilent pour la première fois au pas
militaire
ces jeunes s'apprêtent à quitter la vie
civile leur tenue ne sont pas vraiment
réglementaires leur formation militaire
commence à peine dans les rangs dieu
merci et très motivé et fier d'avoir
répondu à l'appel du président Félix
Tshisekedi à son rôle dans l'armée pour
combattre les rebelles du M23
je suis venu parce que les ennemis nous
envahissent nos frères se battent dans
la brousse contre eux et nous voulons
défendre notre pays
comme lui près de 3000 jeunes selon
l'armée vont suivre une formation
accélérée au programme beaucoup
d'exercices physiques avec toujours en
tête l'urgence de faire face au groupe
armées qui gagnent du terrain dans l'est
du pays est à notre porte ici ne sont
pas très loin d'ici c'est sur nos jeunes
militaires qui sont en train de fixer
ces ennemis même maintenant là ils sont
chez nous vous êtes informés que ils
sont chez nous ils ne sont plus au
Rwanda loin du front à Kinshasa la
société civile s'inquiète de cet
enroulement des jeunes mob pour défendre
le pays et selon ce militant une bonne
chose mais le problème c'est aussi dans
l'armée elle-même c'est d'abord à côté
tous ces mauvais tout tout c'est top là
qui sont dans l'armée c'est très très
belle ces gens qui collaborent avec les
groupes armés qui vendent les munitions
de l'armée et d'autres criminées qui
doivent être déférés devant la justice
aussi longtemps que cela n'est pas fait
ça va on va on va toujours tenir ces
gens de discours et la population ne
pourra pas se mobiliser selon des
sources sécurité l'armée congolaise
aurait bombardé ce mardi plusieurs
positions du groupe armé accusé d'être
soutenu par le Rwanda ces dernières
semaines le M23 a pris le contrôle de
plusieurs localités comme rouchourou
centre faisant craindre une arrivée des
rebelles à Goma le chef-lieu du Nord qui
vous
la frontière entre le Burundi et le
Rwanda rouvrent pour la première fois
depuis 7 ans elle avait été fermée en
2015 suite à une crise électorale et une
tentative de coup d'État au Burundi
après une main tendue de Kigali et dit
égard a annoncé enfin octobre la
réouverture de la totalité de ses
frontières reportage de clémentine
les premières allées venues depuis 7 ans
fin octobre le Burundi a officiellement
rouvert toutes ses frontières cet
enseignante par voir sa famille pour la
première fois depuis des années
je vais enfin revoir mes sœurs ma
famille me manque leur cuisine
bourrontaise me manque aussi comme les
petits poissons l'huile de palme j'en
avais vraiment envie en 2015 le Burundi
en pleine crise politique ferme ses
frontières c'est le début de septembre
d'isolement et de froid avec le Rwanda
que son voisin accuse d'héberger les
auteurs d'une tentative de coup d'État
mais après des années de négociation les
barrières s'abaissent enfin avancé
tension le commerce entre les deux pays
était essentiel à l'économie régionale
on commence
à transiter peut-être dans l'avenir du
forum la semaine prochaine et le
président rwandais va visiter notre
président ça c'est un pas vraiment pour
les villages frontaliers la reprise des
échanges est urgente la crise
ukrainienne a fait grimper le coût de la
nourriture de 34% au Rwanda selon l'ONU
sur ce marché Joseph peinard a acheté
des pour sa famille
avec la frontière ouverte on s'attend à
ce que les prix soient réduits parce que
de nombreux produits viendront du
Burundi et nos marchandises
s'exporteront aussi là-bas
malgré la réouverture 48000 réfugiés
sont encore au Rwanda selon l'ONU la
plupart sont arrivés après la crise de
2015 comme cet ancien militant de
l'opposition il dit avoir fait pour des
raisons politiques et craindre le
nouveau régime une fois qu'il y a une
stabilité politique et faut qu'il y a
une espace pour l'expression donc il y a
beaucoup de choses à changer pour qu'on
se sent un sac en sécurité pour y
retourner selon plusieurs organisations
internationales ont dépit des espoirs
suscités par l'élection du président de
l'alchimie en 2020 il reste de nombreux
efforts à faire en matière de liberté
d'expression
internationale qui s'inquiète du sort de
deux activistes guinéens ou marsilla
alias phonique et Ibrahim Diallo tous
deux leader du Front national pour la
défense de la Constitution ont été
arrêtés en août dernier suite à des
manifestations ils ont entamé lundi une
grève de la fin pour protester contre
leur détention illégales sans jugement
la correspondance à Conakry de Malik
Diakité
Omar Sylla alias phonique et manga
Ibrahim Diallo ont été arrêtés enfin
j'ai à Conakry suite à une manifestation
du Front national pour la défense de la
Constitution interdite par les
militaires au pouvoir ils sont inculpés
pour des faits présumés notamment de
participation à un attroupement interdit
trouble à l'ordre public destruction de
bien en public et privés des accusations
qu'ils ont toujours rejeté en bloc pour
Amnesty International les droits de
l'homme sont régulièrement bafoués en
Guinée les jeunes ne doivent pas
observer une grève de la fin juste pour
comparer devant un juge parce que quand
vous prenez le code pénal et le code de
procédure pénale le principe c'est la
liberté non la détention donner en
période d'exception mais cela ne doit
pas justifier en fait la violation des
droits de l'homme aujourd'hui la liberté
d'expression est soufre parce que tous
les jours il y a des journalistes qui
sont suspendus à liberté de
manifestation déjà est suspendue depuis
l'arrivée des militaires au pouvoir ce
qui est très inquiétant aussi selon
leurs avocats l'état de santé de cette
deux opposants c'est fortement dégradé
suite à les conditions de détention pour
leur aucune date on a encore été annoncé
par la justice guinéenne pour la tenue
de leur procès
on part à présent au Niger dans la
région d'agadeth où l'entreprise
canadienne globale atome et Corporation
a lancé ses premiers travaux pour une
nouvelle mine d'uranium un secteur où
l'entreprise française aura nos
anciennement Areva al monopole
aujourd'hui les populations locales qui
voient ces entreprises se partager le
marché souhaitent voir de véritables
retombées économiques et on appelle aux
autorités pour que ces investissements
se traduisent en infrastructure qui
améliore leur quotidien les explications
à Niamey darrol Girard
l'entreprise canadienne globale atomique
Corporation exploitera l'uranium du site
de Dassa situé à peu près à 50 km au
nord de la ville d'Agadez plus de 180
millions d'euros seront investis pour
mettre en place tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour l'exploitation de
l'uranium à cet endroit mais pour
l'instant la direction de Global
atomique n'a toujours pas annoncé de
plan de financement d'infrastructures
dans la région c'est pourtant ceux
qu'attendent les habitants les
associations nigériennes de leur côté
elles dénonce depuis plusieurs décennies
maintenant le manque de retombées
économique concrète dans le pays du
secteur minier un secteur minier qui est
dominé côté
uranium depuis plusieurs décennies
effectivement par l'entreprise française
Orano anciennement appelé Areva nous
nous voulons à ce que la jeunesse puisse
conquérir ou bien puisse avoir du
travail dans les nouveaux entreprises et
qu'on donne droit aux jeunes locaux
pour que vraiment les économies
retombées pour que la population de la
commune d'Arlit de la région d'agadesh
en bénéficié la pauvreté et le chômage
ont gangrené la région d'Agadez depuis
que l'insécurité a fait fuir les
touristes une partie des populations de
ces zones se sont donc tournés vers leur
paillage illégal qui est un des facteurs
principaux aujourd'hui de l'augmentation
de la violence dans le nord du Niger
ce mouvement social chez Kenya Airways
4e jour de grève pour les pilotes qui
demandent le versement de leur salaire
impayés pendant l'arrêt des vols liés au
covid et de leur cotisations de retraite
il réclame également le renvoi des
dirigeants de la société des dirigeants
qui n'entendent pas accéder aux
revendications de leurs employés et qui
ont fait appel à la justice comme nous
l'explique notre correspondant anaérobie
Bastien grenouille
les pilotes de kenyaways doivent
reprendre le travail avant 6h ce
mercredi matin c'est ce qu'a donné la
juge chargée de faire appliquer le droit
du travail ici au Kenya une grève
illégale qui a commencé samedi matin qui
a bloqué plus de 10000 personnes et fait
plusieurs millions de repères pour
gagner Airways les pilotes s'ils ne
reprenait pas le travail avant ce
mercredi s'expose à de lourdes sanctions
de la part de la justice kenyan qui des
sanctions qui peuvent aller jusqu'à une
période de détention à la compagnie
aérienne la justice a ordonné de ne pas
prendre de sanctions contre ces pilotes
de ne pas les renvoyer car je cite ils
sont essentiels à la vie économique du
pays pourtant kenyaways avait déjà
entamé un bras de fer avec ces derniers
puisque elle a publié à plusieurs
reprises sur les réseaux sociaux des
offres d'emploi pour recruter de
nouveaux pilotes afin de remplacer les
grévistes au pilote enfin s'ils
acceptent de reprendre le travail et
bien la Cour a promis de les aider dans
leur démarche puisque les négociations
sont extrêmement mal engagées entre la
compagnie aérienne et l'Association des
pilotes l'accompagner aérienne refuse de
discuter avec avec eux notamment ces
dirigeants un refusent de d'entamer des
négociations et les pilotes et bien
demandent le départ de ces dirigeants
voient donc mal comment les négociations
pourraient évoluer au cours des
prochains jours
en bref le président français Emmanuel
Macron va officiellement annoncer ce
mercredi la fin de l'opération
antidjihadiste par Cannes une annonce à
l'occasion de la présentation du chef de
l'état de la nouvelle revue stratégique
de la France dictée par la guerre en
Ukraine elle intervient un peu moins de
3 mois après le retrait des forces
françaises du Mali
[Musique]
la question financière est au coeur de
cette cop27 et selon un dernier rapport
les pays du Sud auront besoin de plus de
2000 milliards de dollars par an d'ici
2030 pour financer leurs actions près de
la moitié de cette somme doit provenir
d'investisseurs extérieurs notamment des
pays développés Cécile Galou
pour la première fois en 27 ans l'aide
des pays riches au plus pauvres est au
cœur de la conférence internationale à
l'image de ce rapport commandé par la
présidence de la Coop qui s'appuie sur
un chiffre alarmant 2400 milliards de
dollars c'est le montant que les pays du
Sud doivent trouver par an d'ici 2030
pour financer leur action climatique des
pays du Sud qui réclament une fois de
plus une forte solidarité des pays
développés
financés par nos propres moyens nos
efforts d'adaptation à une situation
dans nos pays sont plutôt victimes est
assurément une double peine
que nous ne sommes pas disposés à subir
des benchmark les critères d'atténuation
d'adaptation et de financement du climat
pour les nations développées comme les
États-Unis le Royaume-Uni l'Australie la
Norvège le Japon et la Russie
ne peuvent pas être les mêmes que les
critères pour les nations en
développement comme le Malawi le
Mozambique et Madagascar
selon le rapport sur les 2400 milliards
de dollars 1000 milliards doivent
promener des pays développés le document
avance même des pistes concrètes de
financement notamment un remaniement des
banques multilatérales de développement
ou une augmentation des prêts à taux
faibles ou nuls des pays du Nord
cela impose alors une grande
responsabilité aux économies développées
d'honorer leurs engagements
reste à savoir si les pays du Nord vont
enfin tenir leurs engagements car ils
n'ont pas encore respecté ce qu'ils
avaient pris lors de la COP 21 à Paris
il s'était pourtant engagé à fournir
entre 2020 et 2025 100 milliards de
dollars par an au plus pauvre en
attendant aucune décision ne devrait
déboucher de cette coupe 2027 les
discussions devraient courir jusqu'en
c'est la fin de journal de l'Afrique
restez avec nous l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]
événement
deux ans après sa victoire Joe Biden
va-t-il conserver sa majorité au Congrès
Donald Trump et les républicains vont
tout faire pour l'en empêcher avec nos
envoyer spéciaux déployés aux quatre
coins des États-Unis nos spécialistes et
invités en plateau découvrez les
résultats de ces élections de mi-manda
crucial pour l'avenir du pays
éditions spéciales élections de
mi-mandat aux États-Unis à suivre sur
France 24 et France 24 com